i have never been an xbox guy i've
always been a playstation
nintendo dude growing up my gaming
identity was formed alongside
zombies and narrow corridors paul
phoenix's hair
and that one gymnast italian plumber
dude i skipped the green helmet guy the
chainsaw bros in the bathroom choirs
because
frankly it was never really my back and
yet
for the past five months of this latest
gaming generation
i have only been playing my xbox
over the past couple of years xbox has
managed to change its entire identity
from the console that came pre-packaged
with a headset
used to talk [ __ ] to randoms on the
internet to the one that wants you to
play more games
how you want with more people like your
grandma
and i am a hundred and ten percent
here for it which is really odd for me
to admit because
well how did xbox go
from the bro gamer console of choice
to the system meant for everyone
including me
and grandma
let's back up xbox slammed into cn in
2001 it was a big bulky dude with a lot
of attitude
and i couldn't care less because it
wasn't a playstation 2. besides was it
backwards compatible with jackie chan
stuntmaster
no could have played tekken 4 no it did
have that one fighting game with the big
arms but the only thing big i cared
about was paul's
hair still i played halo with my friends
shouting obscenities in the privacy of a
musty unfinished basement surrounded
around mountain dew cans
and frozen pizza it was fun don't get me
wrong but when i went back home i wasn't
pining to get back and shoot it out in
the blood gulch i was more concerned
with tending to my pikmin because
dweeb and i own it
roland 2005 the xbox 360 hits the floor
running starting the next generation of
gaming a full year ahead of nintendo
and playstation and i still didn't care
because i was busy playing resident evil
4 for the
28th time thank you still
yet again i found myself in a friend's
basement playing not halo
the gears of war and something else was
different we were still shouting
obscenities but
this time not at one another in private
but into a headset
at strangers over xbox live i watched as
my male
counterparts formed a tribe-like bond
with these other players
they had repeated sessions routinely
planned every week
online bromances formed over halo 3 call
of duty 4 and
gears with their gamer tags boosting a
player formed
clan name and honestly it was kind of
amazing seeing these strangers connect
in this way endearing really but it all
equally very quickly started to feel
like one
big gamer for eternity and so
the xbox bro was born and i
was not one of them now it's important
that i mention that i'm not really
judging the bro gamer i just sought
value from games in a different way
and it's also important i mentioned that
the bro gamer just didn't exist in this
bubble of
xbox in fact bro culture was the most
prevalent in
the mid to early 2000s look no further
than the american pie trilogy or van
wilder or any number of arena based
multiplayer shooters
welcome to unreal tournament everyone
terms like bromance entered the oxford
dictionary in 2001
and over the following decade bro
affiliated terms began popping up
more and more bro hug bro down bohemian
most of which found their way into
esteemed publications like the new york
times
and xbox rose alongside it writing its
highest wave of success
with the boom of the bro and that wasn't
entirely
a coincidence either xbox game designer
daniel cook wrote a blog in 2013 and
said
microsoft worked on marketing campaigns
that put
quote machoism ultra violence and chimp
boys with backwards caps
in the spotlight he even called the xbox
a pre-packaged group
identity machine ouch
okay so here's where we're at bro
culture
was a thing and xbox wanted to cultivate
that again
i'm not judging there was some good
stuff that came out of it
but what sticks out to me the most is
that i finally
understand why i couldn't find a place
in the xbox
community it's not that i was projecting
that onto xbox it's that
xbox was projecting that onto me and
i wasn't really into it so seeing cook's
blog
in a lot of ways really validated my
feelings on the whole thing
but the story continues
the xbox one stumbled out of the gate
and i had already stopped paying
attention to xbox altogether however
during the years following
something interesting began to happen i
was doomed scrolling through twitter
when i locked eyes with xbox again and
something
was different about it its hair was cut
it got into shape
and it had a charming smile on its face
and
it was wearing a double fine t-shirt
wait what the [ __ ]
wait what as would churn out while i was
looking away
microsoft had acquired one of my
favorite gaming studios
double fine left and right xbox began
making choices that made me look at the
console through an entirely different
lens
i began seeing opportunities for gamers
in a way that wasn't
front and center before the chance for a
catalog of games to find new audiences
in a way that was more accessible than
ever
and most recently encouraged me not to
play games with my frat
gamer bros but grandma it was the first
time that xbox was making bold decisions
that
somehow felt as though they were
directed right
at me gone are the days where xbox
packaged a headset with xbox live and on
with the days where me
the gamer and what i want to play and
how i play it
felt like the center of attention and
you know this isn't about
my judgment of culture or who is defined
as a bro it's about how xbox became
more than that and eventually won
someone over
who had no interest in what the brand
had to offer just a few years prior
so yeah game pass is awesome we know
that
but that service is all but a cog in the
gaps the xbox
is closing and the bridges it's creating
by making an entry point
for everyone from the casual gamer to
the hardcore
regardless of age generation or
accessibility requirements
all of which is bookended with a clear
choice to invest in creative developers
not trying to cash in on one specific
demographic but to propel gaming
as the medium it was intended to be a
space
for everyone i don't know what an xbox
bro is these days
but you know what i think i am one
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
megatron's here to watch me do my outro
yo folks
thanks for indulging me on this journey
of
to brodem again this is just my own
personal opinion and journey and if you
utterly disagree with me that's okay you
can leave it in the comments
that's what they're for and to say nice
things if you want
i read them so i will know mean or nice
if you're new here i'm curt this is
gamespot welcome
subscribe if your heart desires and all
that jazz and notifications
you know whatever suits you best anyways
we do a bunch of xbox content we do a
bunch of video game content so
if that's a thing you like then consider
sticking around here
okay be well play your games regardless
of
what console they're on you're cool no
matter what okay
[Music]
bye
you